space the final frontier I first heard
these words when I was just six years
old and I was completely inspired I
wanted to explore strange new worlds
I wanted to seek out new life I wanted
to see everything that the universe had
to offer and those dreams those words
they took me on a journey a journey of
discovery through school through
University to do a PhD and finally to
become a professional astronomer now I
learned two amazing things one slightly
unfortunate when I was doing my PhD I
learned that the reality was I wouldn't
be piloting a starship any time soon but
I also learned that the universe is
strange wonderful and vast actually too
vast to be explored by spaceship and so
I turned my attention to astronomy to
using telescopes now I show you before
you an image of the night sky you might
see it anywhere in the world and all of
these stars are part of our local galaxy
the Milky Way if you were to go to a
darker part of the sky and a nice dark
site perhaps in the desert you might see
the center of our Milky Way galaxy
spread out before you hundreds and
billions of stars and it's a very
beautiful image it's colorful and again
this is just a local corner of our
universe you can see there's a sort of
strange dark dust across it now that
that is local dust that's obscuring the
light of the stars but we can do a
pretty good job just with our own eyes
we can explore a little corner of the
universe it's possible to do better you
can use wonderful telescopes like the
Hubble Space Telescope now astronomers
have put together this image is called
the Hubble Deep Field and they spent
hundreds of hours observing just a tiny
patch of sky no larger than your
thumbnail held at arm's length and in
this image you can see thousands of
galaxies and we know that there must be
hundreds of millions billions of
galaxies in the entire universe
some like our own and some very
different so you think okay well I can
continue this journey this is easy
I can just use a very powerful telescope
and just look at the sky no problem it's
actually really missing out if we if we
just do that now that's because
everything I've talked about so far it's
just using the visible spectrum just the
thing that your eyes can see and that's
a tiny slice a tiny tiny slice of what
the universe has to offer us
now there's also two very important
problems with using visible light so not
only are we missing out on all the other
processes for emitting other kinds of
light but there's two issues now the
first is that dust that I mentioned
earlier the dust stops the visible light
from getting to us so as we look deeper
into the universe we see less light the
dust stops are getting to us but it's a
really strange problem with using
visible light in order to try and
explore the universe now take a break
for a minute
say you're standing on a corner a busy
street corner there's cars going by and
ambulance approaches has a high-pitched
siren me or any Ernie or near near near
noon the siren appeared to change in
pitch as it moved towards and away from
you the ambulance driver did not change
the siren just to mess with you
that was a product of your perception
the sound waves as the ambulance
approached were compressed and they
changed higher in pitch as the ambulance
receded the sound waves are stretched
and they sounded lower in pitch the same
thing happens with light object moving
towards us there light waves are
compressed and they appear bluer objects
moving away from us their light waves
are stretched and there appear redder so
we call these effects blue shift and red
shift now our universe is expanding so
everything is moving away from
everything else and that means
everything appears to be red and oddly
enough as you look more deeply into the
universe more distant objects are moving
away further and faster so they appear
more red so if I come back to the Hubble
Deep Field and we were to continue to
peer deeply into the universe
just using the Hubble as we get to a
certain distance away everything becomes
red and that presents something of a
problem eventually we get so far away
everything is shifted into the infrared
and we can't see anything at all so
there must be a way around this
otherwise I'm limited in my journey I
wanted to explore the whole universe not
just whatever I can see with for the
redshift kicks in there is a technique
it's called Radio Astronomy astronomers
have been using this for decades it's a
fantastic technique I'll show you the
Parkes radio telescope affectionately
known as the dish you may have seen the
movie and radio is really brilliant it
allows us to peer much more deeply it
doesn't get stopped by dust so you can
see everything in the universe and
redshifted less of a problem because we
can build receivers that receive across
a large band so what does Park see when
we turn into the center of the Milky Way
we should see something fantastic right
well if you see something interesting
all that dust has gone as I mentioned
radio goes straight through dust so not
a problem but the view is very different
we can see that the center of the Milky
Way is a glow and this is in starlight
this is a light called synchrotron
radiation and it's formed from electrons
spiraling around cosmic magnetic fields
so that their plane is aglow with this
light and we can also see strange Tufts
coming off of it an object which don't
appear to line up with anything that we
can see with our own eyes but it's hard
to really interpret this image because
as you can see it's very low resolution
radio waves have a wavelength that's
long and that makes their resolution
poorer this image is also black or white
so we don't really know what is the
color of everything in here or
fast-forward to today we can build
telescopes which can get over these
problems I'm showing you here an image
of the Murchison radio Observatory a
fantastic place to build radio
telescopes it's flat it's dry and most
importantly it's radio quiet no mobile
phones no Wi-Fi nothing
just very very radio quiet so perfect
place to build a radio telescope now the
telescope that I've been working on for
a few years it's called the Murchison
widefield array I'm going to show you a
little time-lapse of it being built this
is a group of undergraduate and
postgraduate students are located in
Perth we call them the student army and
they volunteered their time to build a
radio telescope there's no course credit
in this and they're putting together
these radio dipoles they just receive at
low frequencies a bit like your FM radio
or your TV and here we are deploying
them across the desert the final
telescope covers 10 square kilometers of
the Western Australian desert and the
interesting thing is there's no moving
parts we just deploy these little
antennas essentially on chicken mesh
fairly cheap cables take the signals
from the antennas and bring them to
central processing units and it's the
size of this telescope the fact that
we've built it over the entire desert
that gives us a better resolution than
Parkes
now eventually all those cables bring
them through a unit which sends it off
to a supercomputer here in Perth and
that's where I come in radio data I have
spent the last five years working with
very difficult very interesting data
that no one had really looked at before
I've spent a long time calibrating it
running millions of CPU hours on
supercomputers and really trying to
understand that data and with with this
telescope with this data we've performed
a survey of the entire southern sky the
Galactic and extra galactic or sky MW a
survey or gleam cycle and I'm very
excited this survey is just about to be
published but it hasn't been shown yet
so you are literally the first people to
see this southern survey of the entire
sky so I'm delighted to share with you
some images from this earth now imagine
you went to the Murchison and you camped
out underneath the Stars and you look
towards the south you saw the South
celestial Pole the galaxies rising I
fade in the radio light
this is what we observe with our survey
you can see that the Galactic plane is
no longer dark with dust it's a light
with synchrotron radiation and thousands
of dots are in the sky our Large
Magellanic Cloud our nearest galactic
neighbor is orange instead of it's more
familiar blue-white so there's a lot
going on in this let's take a closer
look if we look back towards the
galactic center where we originally saw
the Parkes image that I showed you
earlier low resolution black and white
we fade to the gleam view you can see
the resolution has gone up by a factor
of 100 we now have a color view of the
sky a technical of you now it's not a
false color view these are real radio
colors what I've done is I've colored
the lowest frequencies red and the
highest frequencies blue in the middle
ones green and that gives us this
rainbow view and this isn't just fourth
color the colors in this image tell us
about the physical processes going on in
the universe so for instance if you look
along the plane of the galaxy it's a
light with synchrotron which is mostly
reddish orange but if we look very
closely we see little blue dots now if
we zoom in these blue dots are ionized
plasma around very bright stars and what
happens is that they block the red light
so they appear blue and these can tell
us about these star forming regions in
our galaxy and we just see them
immediately we look at the galaxy and
the color tells us that they're there
you can see little soap bubbles little
circular images around the Galactic
plane and these are supernova remnants
when a star explodes its outer shell is
cast off and it travels outward into
space gathering up material and it
produces a little shell it's been a
long-standing mystery to astronomers
where all the supernova remnant are we
know that there must be a lot of
high-energy electrons in the plane to
produce the synchrotron radiation that
we see we think they're produced by
supernova remnants but they don't seem
to be enough
fortunately gleam is really really good
at detecting supernova remnants so we're
hoping to have
rattle Nazi now that's fine we've we've
explored our little local universe but I
wanted to go deeper I wanted to go
further I wanted to go beyond the Milky
Way well as it happens we can see a very
interesting object in the top right and
this is a local radio galaxy Centaurus a
if we zoom in on this we can see that
there are two huge plumes going out into
space
and if you look right in the center of
between those two plumes you'll see a
galaxy just like our own safar alit has
a dust lane it's that normal galaxy but
these these Jets are only visible in the
radio if we looked in the visible we
wouldn't even know they were there and
there are thousands of times larger than
the host galaxy what's going on what's
producing these Jets at the center of
every galaxy that we know about is a
supermassive black hole our black holes
are invisible why they call that all you
can see is the deflection of the light
around them and occasionally when a star
or a cloud of gas comes into their orbit
it is ripped apart by tidal forces
forming what we call an accretion disk
the accretion disk glows brightly in the
x-rays and huge magnetic fields can
launch the material into space at nearly
the speed of light so these Jets are
visible in the radio and this is what we
pick up in our survey all very well so
we've seen one radio galaxy that's nice
but if you just look at the top of that
image you'll see another radio galaxy
it's a little bit smaller and that's
just because it's further away
okay two radio galaxies we can see this
which is fine well what about all the
other dots presumably those are just
stars they're not they're all radio
galaxies every single one of the dots in
this image is a distant galaxy
millions to billions of light-years away
with a supermassive black hole at its
center pushing material into space at
nearly the speed of light it is
mind-blowing and this survey is even
larger than what I've shown here if we
zoom out to the full extent of the
survey you can see I found three
hundred thousands of these radio
galaxies so it's truly an epic journey
with we've discovered all of these
galaxies right back to the very first
supermassive black holes I'm very proud
of this and it will be published next
week now that's not all I've explored
the farthest reaches of the galaxy with
this survey but there's something even
more in this image now I take you right
back to the dawn of time when the Hyatt
when the universe formed it was a Big
Bang which made which left the universe
as a sea of hydrogen neutral hydrogen
and when the very first stars and
galaxies switched on they ionize that
hydrogen so the universe went from
neutral to ionized that imprinted a
signal all around us everywhere it
pervades us workforce now because that
happened so long ago the signal was red
shifted so now that signal isn't very
low frequencies it's at the same
frequency as mysurvey but it's so faint
it's a billionth the size of any of the
objects in my survey so our our
telescope may not be quite sensitive
enough to pick up this signal however
there's a new radio telescope so I can't
have a starship but I can hopefully have
one of the biggest radio telescopes in
the world we're building the Square
Kilometre Array a new radio telescope
and it's going to be a thousand times
bigger than the MWA a thousand times
more sensitive and have an even better
resolution so we should find tens of
millions of galaxies and perhaps deepen
that signal
I will get to look upon the very first
stars and galaxies switching on the
beginning of time itself thank
[Applause]
you
[Music]